As heavy combat between Russia and Ukraine continues in Eastern Ukraine,
supplies on both sides are running low so far in the war,
countries around the world have been involved in providing equipment.
The red on this map shows the nations that have pledged weapons to support Kiev and the
blues shows the countries that have persisted.
Moscow according to Western intelligence aid for has been widely
publicized while Russia's deals have been largely shrouded in secrecy.
Satellite images on the ground footage and customs documents analyzed
by the Wall Street Journal,
tell us more about the nation's supporting Russia's war machine.
North Korea is one nation that has been supplying weapons to Russian fighters.
According to the Biden administration,
us,
intelligence said the mercenary force of Wagner has received infantry rockets and
missiles from the country.
The White House released satellite images that it said shows five Russian rail cars
participating in the weapons transfer in a return trip from Hassan in
Russia to Tung in North Korea.
This image also shows a nearby open air storage unit which military
analysts said facilitated the delivery in response to the US in
November,
North Korea denied supplying weapons to Russia and said it had no plans to do so.
Russia's embassy in Washington didn't respond to a request for comment,
deliveries of ammunition are crucial for Russia to continue its intensive fighting
as the war largely becomes one of attrition.
But in a sign that stocks are running low,
Russia has launched fewer shells in recent weeks than last year.
Military analysts estimate that Moscow's forces are now firing 10,000
shells a day down from 20,000 to 30,000 last
summer.
That's still well above Ukraine which fires an estimated 3000 day
and is also struggling with low stockpiles.
Russia is also receiving support from Iran.
Ukrainian officials say Moscow has used hundreds of Iranian drones to hit
civilian and military targets.
Iran has acknowledged publicly that it has supplied drones to Russia.
Military.
Analysts say drones consistent with Iranian self destructive unmanned aerial
vehicles can be seen in these videos of strikes in
Moscow and Tehran are also moving to build a new factory in Russia that could make at
least 6000 Iranian designed drones in the coming years.
Drone attacks have been a key tactic used by both Russia and Ukraine in the
war.
Ukraine's military has posted videos like this one that it said showed strikes
on Russian targets using Turkish made drones
and then there's China,
both the US and China say Beijing hasn't provided weapons to Russia by
Russian customs records provided to the Wall Street Journal in February by The Center for
Advanced Defense Studies,
a Washington based nonprofit show that China has indirectly supported
Moscow's war efforts.
The records show that Chinese state owned companies provided Russian government owned
defense firms with navigation equipment,
jamming technology and jet fighter parts.
Russia's embassy in Washington didn't respond to a request for comment.
A month later,
Chinese leader Xi Jinping traveled to Moscow for a multi day summit
deepening economic ties between the two nations.
Us.
Officials say China is also considering supplying artillery and drones to
Russia.
China has denied it is considering such action and has in turn
pointed a finger at the US and its allies for fueling the conflicts by
providing Ukraine with weapons.
Russia is gathering its forces as it attempts to break Ukrainian defenses
across the eastern Donetsk region,
looking to its allies could help Moscow as Kev begins to receive a large cache
of Western made heavy weapons as the war continues
outside partnerships could prove to be vital as both Russia and Ukraine
prepare for fighting to intensify in the coming weeks.